personally like I'm coming from the
cyber security space and actually when
we um walked into this problem which is
just basically a fch problem um you you
start you need to start using I think a
new terminology which is much more of a
financial terminology right so the
simplest way to think about consumer
protection is like two things one you
know I put my money or my value
into those assets on this new technology
I go go to sleep I wake up in the
morning I need to make sure that they
are still there right so fundamentally
to protect it against death when I'm
sending a transaction to you I need to
make sure that it's not being fished or
spoofed and the the interesting thing is
that it's like a very new set of
problems compared to the way that the
traditional Financial ecosystem
[Music]
Works Michael shaulov welcome to 20
minute lism so happy to have you here H
obviously it's such a crazy world that
we're living in you're living and
leading one of the most uh I think
important and amazing um you know
changes that are fundamentally changing
the way we're interacting with with
assets and with with what we consider as
you know tools that we that help us
engage in in this world and so really
excited to be speaking to you both about
this problem space you know where this
is heading but also your own person
personal Journey so thank you very much
for being here of course thanks Michael
for having me again of course definitely
so so Michael you know let's let's get
into digital assets you know what you
know give me a little bit of an overview
as to you know what is this even the
space that we're talking about and and
how how did you get really into this
space yeah sure so I think the easiest
way to think about it that this is um
once in a century sort of almost a
transformation of the backbone and the
plumbing of the financial system right
and this is like you know actually the
usage of public blockchains and what we
in our own world calling like you know
the crypto rails and the transformation
and the implications it has for the
worldwi economy and I think uh and
probably like a lot of implica future
implications around how um you know
Financial assets other assets and just
generally speaking things that we value
right just like Basic Value is can
actually be transported and interacted
over the internet and the simplest way
to understand this is that uh when I
tell people like okay if you want to
browse to a Japanese website right so
let's say you're in the US you're in
Israel or you're anywhere else in the
world and you want to go into a Japanese
website you know you basically type
something in your web browser. JP you
know takes less than a second to load on
your website you don't pay anything to
anyone right there just like a few bits
that are going from that part of of the
world to your part of the world in
lights in the light in in the speed of
light right now if you want to send $200
to Japan that will take you anywhere
between three days and a week right and
it will cost you anywhere between $50 to
$120 depending on the setup that you
have with your bank right and or or 3%
right if you're doing the transaction
over a credit card and then you should
ask yourself a question okay but why is
that the issue because even when I'm
transferring money right now this is
just like a bunch of bits that are going
from one database to a different
database right that's the only thing
that is happening right you're not
basically shipping an envelope with
dollars in it and the reason for that is
that the entire system is basically at
best what was set up in the 70s predates
the internet and a lot of like the ideas
are actually like you even older and
they go about like you know 100 to 500
years ago and that's how the financial
system really works right and all the
Innovation all the fexs that happened
over the last couple of decades they
only sort of like you know patches on
top of that infrastructure and the
interesting thing about blockchain and
the first thing that actually came in
terms of the Innovation is SK like
Bitcoin which was like the Revolutionary
idea was that you have a system in which
you can natively transfer value over the
internet at the speed of the internet
without any intermediaries without
relying on a set or linkage of
underlying financial institutions and
Banks and that was like
transformative and this entire notion
has huge
implications uh on how the financial
system is going to look moving forward
and um and that has implications to
anyone from like you know if you want to
send or pay five dollar right to the
other side of the world to um Government
funding you know uh Tre like uh treas
IES bonds capital markets and even other
areas that are currently not considered
like Financial activity for example in
game economy when you're buying a
virtual good in uh your favorite online
game all those things can actually be
built together and uh this is I think
like you know the the really exciting
part that we are
in and so there's incredible upsides to
and to engaging in this digital
transformation you're you're touching on
the most fundamental ones I think which
are talking about our ability to engage
in in in in in trade and in in transfers
both in terms of latency but also in
terms of not not losing and not paying
for the transactions just like we're not
paying to to to to browse websites in
general um but there's obviously
mountains in the way to get us to
translate our existing Financial systems
to this new to this new Financial system
and and at fire blocks I understand
you're you're tackling and you're
helping mitigate a big mountain in the
way in the in the world of security H
but but what are those big pillars that
we Are Climbing over these years to get
us to that new world yeah so I think
like you know the first the first
uh um Mountain that uh was standing in
between us and actually that future was
really is this technology can you
actually put it in practice and uh
luckily I think over the last decade and
probably in the last three four years
that mountain was cleared right so we
have real companies doing billions of
dollars of transfers and actually like
sort of like ripping the benefits um a
lot of them are sitting on the fire
blocks infrastructure ripping the
benefits for their new business model
that was like a big mon Big Mountain
just basically the validation of the
technology and it can actually be used
at scale the second component and maybe
like you know the second two components
that almost like you know go hand inand
is basically security compliance and
just generally speaking consumer
protection right so um you know I'm my
personally like I'm coming from the
cyber security space and actually when
we um walked into this problem which is
just basically a fintech problem um you
you start you need to start using I
think uh a new ter terminology which is
much more of a financial terminology
right so the simplest way to think about
consumer protection is like two things
one you know I put my money or my value
into those assets on this new technology
I go to sleep I wake up in the morning I
need to make sure that they are still
there right so fundamentally to protect
it against St when I'm sending a
transaction to you I need to make sure
that it's not being fished or spoofed
and the the interesting thing is that
it's like a very new set of problems
compared to the way that the traditional
Financial ecosystem works and we'll go
get into that in a second and the second
issue is really things that are much
more around consumer protection and
compliance which is like more uh around
the fact like how do we making sure that
there are no Bad actors right how do we
making sure that this is not being use
the leverage for terrorist financing or
for um human trafficking or things that
are like very clear to all of us that
there are bad things that we don't want
to facilitate how do we making sure that
you know when you're buying an asset
this is actually like you know what is
being Market what what is being marketed
to you is real so all like those two
mountains are generally speaking the two
mountains that um you know regulators
and most of the market most of the
people that want to use it care about
and those are the the issues that we are
tackling and then on top of that like
once we clear those two mountains which
I think we have done quite successfully
so far um there's just basically the
general adoption right so how easy it is
to use how easy it is for newcomers to
adopt this technology and how easy it is
for incumbents and what we call
traditional financial institutions to
start using the technology but the
answer for both of us is actually like
you know regulation uh which we had a
lot of movement over there recently but
the regulation what The Regulators
really care about is that there is a
consumer protection that people are not
getting hurt while we adopting new
technology and that by the way like it's
true we're seeing it with the internet
we're seeing it with blockchain we
seeing it with AI this is just like you
know a common issue across everything
that is new tech right now and and what
is the what are the big Milestones we've
had with regulations very recently that
are now allowing us to to increase that
adoption even more and to engage more
with consumers in the space yeah so I
think like you know the thing that is
basically most uh known that happened in
the last uh month actually is the
approval of the ETFs right in the United
States by the Security and Exchange
Commission and and basically 11 ETFs uh
going live and now available for the
market to trade through the stock
exchange to be honest there are like a
lot of debates of like how much is that
an important milestone for for for the
blockchain itself because it's some ways
you know this is just like um a very
traditional way to access a very new
technology and you can access that
technology directly right so why do you
need the banks to access that but from a
regulatory standpoint that was a huge
milestone and something that the E the
the the ecosystem and uh and the players
in the ecosystem were fighting for for
for the last five six years and in order
to clear that they had to prove to The
Regulators that you can actually
establish guard rails remove Market
manipulation establish consumer
protection that the custody and the
security of the underlying storage of
those Bitcoins that are backing the ETF
are sound and secure and the standard of
the Security and Exchange Commission is
very very high and that was basically we
were going back and forth in terms of
trying to get this thing approved for
the last four or five years and now we
already managed to clear this which
basically means that um assuming that
you implement things correctly you can
actually get to the point where the top
Regulators in the world believe that
okay it's sound enough to be used by the
mainstream and and it sounds like this
is an important Milestone again not not
in terms of the the access right but
more so in terms of the validation to
transition from the early adopters to to
the rest of the world right the long
tail that are perhaps looking at at this
more at this validation as well so I can
assume why why it is an important fight
nevertheless um does do does this have
any impact on volume of trade or do you
anticipate that this is more so the the
second order effects of this of allowing
more people to get comfortable with
engaging with this well I think that
they it has three pillars right so the
first pillar is definitely the direct
volume and trading expectations so for
for those who are listening here the
launch of the Bitcoin ATF for example by
black rock that is the biggest asset
manager in the world that was in the in
the first three days that was the
highest volume that they ever had for
any ETF more than gold more than silver
more more than any composition that they
ever launched the Bitcoin ETF had a
subscription that in the first couple of
days that exceeded any other product
that they ever launched right so first
and foremost it basically shows that
there is a demand H and C drives volume
the the second ER effect is that it
drives the it actually sort of like
almost like a psychological barrier that
was removed as people saw okay the Wall
Street the top Wall Street regulator is
stepping in by the way in an environment
that is still reasonably hostile okay
for for for this Market just to be quite
clear and the third which I think is
goes to much broader than Bitcoin is
that we always look at like you know the
US Regulators but actually this is a
global phenomenon and we're seeing
globally both in Europe and in the UAE
in Japan in Singapore in a lot of other
J jurisdictions the Australia the The
Regulators are actually by the way also
like in Israel The Regulators actually
moving forward much faster than in the
United States they establishing much
cleaner and forward-looking
standards and that enables all the other
beautiful use cases that we actually
seeing H being built on that which
really goes into the mainstream right so
it's not only a question like do I want
to trade Bitcoin do I think that this is
going to the moon or not it's really
like can I use a payment system to do
remittance and transfer a payment to the
Philippines or to Africa or cross border
at a fraction of H the cost and at a
speed and transparency that I couldn't
before do I have the tools do do we know
how to construct assets that are on
chain that are for example one to one p
to the dollar P to the Euro or P to the
Japanese Yen they're not volatile like
Bitcoin and are we able to basically
create treasury basically like treasury
market or bonds that when I don't want
to use the money I can instant L
basically go into an instrument that is
going to pay me 5% for every day sorry
5% like per year but like in an interval
of minutes which is currently not
available in the traditional space
because in the traditional space if I
need now to if I want to buy a money
market fund or I need to invest in any
other product the settlement time is
next day or like over the weekend right
so you you basically able to capture a
lot of value and all those things are
basically being being built on top of
that regulation incredible okay so where
are you at with this so you know you
you're you're coming from the security
space you sold your previous startup to
checkpoint and you were head of product
and of of some of the most important
products within checkpoint uh when you
were coming across the space H how did
you end up starting fire blocks yeah so
um it's actually started like you know
somewhat like from a first principles
standpoint and when I was a checkpoint
uh as you mentioned my our previous
company laon was specialized in Mobile
security we got acquired by checkpoint
and I was uh leading their product uh uh
product product team for mobile and
Cloud at the time and at some point we
did a small part in an investigation
that happened in South Korea so
basically the Lazarus Group which is
Affiliated attributed to the North
Korean they hacked into four
cryptocurrency EX changes in 2016 2017
and they sto what was at the time $200
million worth of bitcoin by the way
Bitcoin was the $1,000 so I think you
can multiply that by 43 and that's the
actual value of that right now and I was
just blown away and I and and the two
two issues that actually came up very
quickly um speaking of first principles
that it was once you kind of read the
Bitcoin white paper and the ethereum
white paper you sort of understood that
this is um a extremely important and
revolutionary underlying technology at
the minimum for the financial market so
for someone who's been uh watching the
transformation of Cloud public cloud in
terms of what it did to the it I kind of
s how one piece of infrastructure has
been completely disrupted right I was
like oh my God this is actually going to
dist trp a much bigger piece of
infrastructure right so you know if you
think about companies we all I mean for
someone comes from cyber security space
you all you know you know two things one
is that the financial spaces ORD of
magnitude bigger than like the from a
from a tam or from market cap than all
of cyber security in it right so Visa
alone has a market cap that exceeds all
the cyber security companies combined I
think um and so you know the opportunity
is Big the second aspect is that by the
way for most of the cyber security
companies 40% of their revenue coming
from the financial sector uh
understandingly why and um and that's
basically a big opportunity so um so
you're basically saying there is a big
problem over there this is like a really
large ter and this is going to be as
transformative
probably like bigger much more
transformative than uh the than U the
the previous uh kind of like you know
examples so
we that was like an interesting
opportunity so what we we we started to
do then is actually follow um a Playbook
that I I recommend to all the
entrepreneurs right which is taking from
a book called four steps to Epiphany and
it's called like customer Discovery so
we started we didn't came from the space
of blockchain um so we started doing
this kind of market research and just
talking with clients and trying to un
prospects actually and trying to
understand what are the pain points they
have what is not working what are the
gaps why are they getting hacked right
why why do they keep losing money and
that basically what established fire
blocks that initially was somewhat of a
I would say we had somewhat of a limited
view in terms of what we're going to do
but very quickly it is expanded to be
this pretty broad infrastructure
platform play for any company financial
institution and non-financial
institution that are accessing digital
assets and cryptocurrencies and we're
basically providing them the entire
backbone of wallets uh settlement ER
capabilities H tokenization capabilities
payment capabilities so five years later
it is a true platform play uh that we
are able to provide to all those clients
incredible so and you know fire blocks
is obviously one of the most well-known
companies in the space what is the
current status of fire blocks in the
market yeah so um I think that uh we are
definitely kind of charging forward with
the market H we are seeing broadly
speaking uh especially after the ETF
approval but even before that um let's
put it this way the end of 2022 is the
collapse of FTX wasn't like a pretty
sight you know to anyone who've been in
the space having said that all the
people that were in the space they
stayed and we kind of rebuilt a lot of
the damage that was done so the second
part of 2023 was kind of was quite help
helpful we started to see a lot of um
Extended utility use cases extended uh
players coming in the regulation become
start to improve so right now we're
definitely seeing the macro uh for the
space continuously improving um our
stage right now that we are working with
over 1500 clients um all of them are
businesses financial institutions our
goal is to basically double triple it uh
this year on the back of a lot of new
people that are coming in um we've done
over I think it's now approaching five
it's way over four trillion dollars I
think approaching five trillion of
dollars that uh uh is moving through our
infrastructure so uh our mission this
year is to do two things one and
continue to support and enable more and
more use cases that help people to
leverage this technology and to help
Regulators to shape the regulation and
basically continue and solve issues
around security around consumer
protection around compliance that they
need which we were doing quite well by
expanding our portfolio and
um and last but not least to start
pushing
forward uh a lot of like you know the
the things which we believe are kind of
the future of H where the space is going
um which you know we are why kind of in
unique position to do that incredible
Michael thank you so much for for taking
the time to come here and this is a I'm
I'm time capsuling this conversation
just like I did with the other one such
a special moment to be talking to to
somebody who's who's charging with the
with the industry and leading it and um
and so I'm very very excited to continue
cheering on and being a fan from the
side and thank you for taking the time
to share this with myself and and
everybody else that's listening thank
you very much yeah of course thanks
Michael
[Music]